up
day two of a chaotic standoff Imran
Khan's home a Battleground
police still pushing to arrest him for
not showing up to court on corruption
charges the government insists it is not
a politically motivated move
so we have seen police firing tear gas
water cannons there have been intense
clashes are you concerned by the images
the only person who should be concerned
at this point in time should be Mr Imran
Khan who has just been uttering blatant
lies since last night because the
government has nothing to do with the
arrest and the arrest has nothing to do
with the delaying of the elections Imran
Khan says that he fears for his life
this is a man who faced an assassination
attempt do you accept that there is a
threat there
you see the thing is that if the guy
says that he's uh he has security
threats and to the guy at this in the
same breath Mr Khan says that he's ready
for all political rallies he's out there
but the moment the court asks him to
appear in the court for his corruption
cases he says I have security threat the
former prime minister denies the charges
against him he emerged today wearing a
gas mask this thought moment both a
threat and opportunity to build
political Capital we are doing
everything
elections all get me out of the way
there is one way is to put me in jail
the other
is to have be killed and then government
itself the interior Ministry has warned
that my life is a danger
the high court in Islamabad eventually
stepped in suspending the operation to
arrest Mr Khan he's promised to appear
in court on Saturday
a pause but far from a resolution
Sky News Pakistan